Thomas Vulcan has had major heart
surgery now whenever he goes out and
thinks that something could be wrong
with his heart he can pull out his mini
ECG monitoring device with the help of
an app called cardio go he can send it
to a cardiologist who will analyze the
data and respond well he can be somebody
solution so far vilkin has only had to
use the app once I have as a zero
positive alpha on the mat very positive
experiences within a very short period
of time just three or four seconds I had
a cardiologist on the phone he cocky
young jeezy not on dere ya blue he took
a look at my acj luckily he said
everything was fine often Athena so
afterwards a patient is relieved and
that's exactly the purpose you can be
certain about it manga Zika sign can
usually vilkin is a patient of
cardiologists yen's Biermann in the town
of adel five years ago Biermann teamed
up with the hamburg-based company llr to
create the cardio go app he had noticed
that many of his patients wanted to feel
secure on weekends and while on vacation
the service cost just under 2,000 euros
including two consultations patients pay
extra for additional consultations but
that gives them access to a specialist
in Germany around the clock a team of 22
cardiologists participate in the program
and whenever necessary they advise
patients to visit a nearby clinic de
Pazzi only guns on unfounded man's
interns or peony other the patients have
been taking part since the beginning are
our pioneers most of them pay for the
service themselves proving that it works
then we can offer it to insurance
companies or maybe even to politicians
so they'll recognize that it could
eventually be made available to everyone
German health insurers are still
skeptical about new health apps
especially when it comes to privacy laws
it's also still unclear which apps are
most practical at the moment insurers
believe patients should deal directly
with the service providers that's mostly
defelice everybody should decide for
themselves if they wanted or not there's
also the issue of whether to make it
available for all 70 million people with
statutory insurance that's good and
there's no concrete proof that these
apps really do offer additional benefits
and mere vet beaten does is not against
Leon movies him bad patients like Thomas
Wilkin are already convinced he would
have paid on his own but due to his
heart disease his insurance provider
agreed to cover a hundred percent of the
costs